ONE MEMBER WHO WOULD SPEAK WITH
US, CONGRESSWOMAN MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE.
>> YOU TAKE THE BIKE TO WORK?
>> SOMETIMES.
>> Reporter: THAT'S CONGRESSMAN
MO BROOKS.
>> CONGRESSMAN CAN WE GET YOU TO
TALK ABOUT JANUARY 6th?
>> I DO NOT TALK WITH CNN
BECAUSE I DO NOT FIND CNN TO BE
HONORABLE OR TRUTHFUL.
>> Reporter: THE SAME MAN WHO
SAID THIS ON JANUARY 6th.
>> TODAY IS THE DAY AMERICAN
PATRIOTS START TAKING DOWN NAMES
AND KICKING ASS.
>> Reporter: SINCE THEN HE'S
PEDDLED THE BOGUS ANTIFA THEORY.
>> I ALREADY SAID WHAT I'M GOING
TO SAY.
>> CAN YOU TELL US IF YOU REGRET
WHAT YOU SAID --
>> I DO NOT TRUST CNN TO BE
TRUTHFUL OR HONEST.
>> I'M ASKING YOU FAIR QUESTIONS
HERE, SIR.
>> I DO NOT TRUST Y'ALL TO BE
TRUTHFUL OR HONEST WITH ANYTHING
CNN DOES.
>> IT'S ON VIDEO.
>> SEE YOU.
>> THEN HE RODE OFF.
>> YOU'LL LIE THROUGH YOUR TEETH
ANY CHANCE YOU GET.
>> WELL, I'LL GIVE YOU THE
CHANCE TO COME ON IF YOU DON'T
MIND.
>> Reporter: WE ALSO CAUGHT UP
WITH MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE WHO
DID AGREE TO STOP AND TALK WITH
US.
DESPITE ALL OF THAT BODY CAM
FOOTAGE SHOWING TRUMP SUPPORTERS
AND RIGHT WING SUPREMISTS.
WHEN WE PRESSED HER FOR EVIDENCE
TO BACK UP HER CLAIMS, SHE
DIDN'T OFFER ANY.
>> YOU'VE SEEN THE VIDEO THAT'S
COME OUT SO FAR.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT VIDEO?
IT SEEMS TO SHOW A LOT OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS INVOLVED IN THE
RIOTING.
>> HERE'S HOW I SEE IT.
>> YEAH.
>> THE AMERICAN TAXPAYERS PAY
FOR EVERYTHING HERE, RIGHT?
THEY PAY FOR THE BUILDING, THEY
PAY FOR THE CAMERAS, THEY PAY
FOR THE STAFF.
THEY PAY FOR MY SALARY.
THEY PAY FOR EVERYTHING AND THIS
IS THE TYPE OF VIDEO THEY
DESERVE TO SEE PUBLICLY.
>> I'M ASKING YOU ABOUT
YOURSELF.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE VIDEO,
DON'T YOU MAINLY SEE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS INVOLVING IN THE
RIOTING?
>> THERE'S ALL KINDS OF PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN RIOTING, BLACK
CLOTHES, RED HATS.
>> OATH KEEPERS.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE'VE READ AND
SEEN.
>> THEY'VE BEEN ARRESTED.
>> RIGHT.
SOME IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT
ALMOST 24 HOURS A DAY IN THE
JAIL HERE.
>> I'M WONDERING F THEY'RE BEING
HELD IN JAIL F THEY'RE IN
SOLITAIRE CONFINEMENT LIKE YOU
SAID WRRK DOES THIS STUFF COME
FROM ABOUT FBI AND ANTIFA, WHERE
IS IT COMING FROM?
>> THESE ARE THE REPORTS THAT
HAVE BEEN COMING OUT,
INFORMATION THAT THERE MAY HAVE
BEEN FBI OPERATIVES.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO WHAT THAT
MEANS.
IS THAT INFORMANTS?
>> WHERE IS THE PROOF THE FBI
WAS INVOLVED?
WHERE'S THE PROOF ANTIFA WAS
INVOLVED?
DON'T YOU OWE IT TO PEOPLE TO
PRODUCE THAT PROOF?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DIDN'T CAUSE THE RIOTS, SO I
CERTAINLY DON'T OWE IT.
>> THERE'S NO EVIDENCE.
>> LOOK.
LOOK.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO
BE ANSWERED.
THERE ARE THINGS.
>> YOU CAN ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT
ANYTHING.
>> AS SHE REPEATEDLY DODGED OUR
QUESTIONS, SHE DID WELCOME NANCY
PELOSI'S ANNOUNCEMENT THAT A
SELECT COMMITTEE WILL
INVESTIGATE THE INSURRECTION.
IN FACT, SHE SAID SHE WANTS TO
BE ON THE COMMITTEE.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO SERVE ON
THE COMMITTEE?
>> SURE.
SHE SHOULD PUT ME ON THE
COMMITTEE.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
>> YOU WOULD SHOW UP AND ASK
QUESTIONS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I WORKED HARD ALL MY LIFE AND I
WOULD WORK HARD THERE AS WELL.
>> Reporter: BUT GREENE HAS SAID
SHE DOESN'T THINK TRUMP IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR JANUARY 6th.
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
HE'S NOT RESPONSIBLE.
THE PEOPLE THAT DID THE THINGS
HERE, THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IT.
>> THEY'RE ON VIDEO SAYING THEY
DID IT FOR TRUMP.
>> WE CAN GO ALL DAY LONG AND
EVERY SINGLE TIME I'M GOING TO
TELL YOU PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOT
TELL THE PEOPLE TO RIOT.
HE TOLD PEOPLE TO MARCH HERE
PEACEFULLY.
>> DO YOU THINK THIS WAS A --
>> I THINK IT WAS A RIOT.
>> BY WHOM?
>> BUY PEOPLE WHO CAME TO THE
CAPITOL.
>> BY THE --
>> I DON'T HAVE A LIST.
IF YOU WANT TO DO YOUR JOB AS A
JOURNALIST.
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN JAIL IN
SOLITAIRE CONFINEMENT.
YOU CAN LOOK UP THEIR NAMES AND
SEE THE CHARGES.
>> HAVE YOU BEEN INVOLVED WITH
ANY OF THEM?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THEY'VE COMMITTED CRIMES AND
THEY'LL HAVE THEIR DAY IN COURT.
>> Reporter: AS FOR THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY ABOUT THE FBI,
GREENE IS WILLING TO ACCEPT THAT
THE BUREAU WASN'T INVOLVED, BUT
SHE WANTS TO, GET THIS, SEE THE
EVIDENCE.
YES, EVEN THOUGH SHE HASN'T
OFFERED ANY PROOF OF HER OWN.
>> BUT IF THE FBI TELLS YOU THEY
DIDN'T HAVE ANY INVOLVEMENT IN
THIS, WOULD YOU BELIEVE THEM?
>> YES, OF COURSE.
>> SOUNDING A LOT LIKE THE
FORMER PRESIDENT, GREENE TALKED
ABOUT THE NEGATIVE COVERAGE
SHE'S RECEIVED LIKE WHEN SHE
COMPARED MASK MANDATES ON
CAPITOL HILL TO THE HOLOCAUST.
>> YOU GUYS AREN'T VERY NICE TO
ME THOUGH.
YOU SAY TERRIBLE THINGS ABOUT ME
ALL THE TIME ON YOUR STATION, SO
IT DOESN'T MAKE ME FEEL VERY
WELCOME OR WANTED TO COME, AND
I'M SURE YOU CAN UNDERSTAND FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE WHY I WOULD FEEL
THAT WAY.
>> WELL, THERE'S BEEN COVERAGE
YOU'VE SAID.
>> THINGS THAT WERE SAID WHEN I
WASN'T --
>> THERE WAS SOMETHING YOU SAID
ABOUT THE HOLOCAUST.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> DID YOU LEARN ANYTHING?
>> I TALKED ABOUT IT OUT HERE.
I HAD A PRESS CONFERENCE.
>> DO YOU THINK MAYBE IT'S TIME
TO CHOOSE YOUR WORDS MORE
CAREFULLY?
>> I THINK YOU NEED TO CHOOSE
YOUR WORDS MORE CAREFULLY.
DO YOU KNOW WHY SO MANY
REPUBLICANS CAN'T STAND CNN
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T CHOOSE YOUR
WORDS.
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF